Mr President I'd like to start with this
how do you believe this war ends only
without victory
a victory Of Truth means victory of
Ukraine and ukrainians
the question is when it will end
that is a deep question
it's a painful question besides Victory
the Ukrainian people will not accept any
outcome what are you willing to agree to
to get a peace deal for example are you
willing to trade any amount of Ukrainian
territory to achieve achieve a peace
deal with Russia
we do not trade our territory
so that the question of territorial
integrity and sovereignty is out of
discussion
there are difficult questions regarding
temporarily occupied territories
there are principal difficulties we are
ready to put off some issues of the
agenda like the Crimean issue we are
prepared to talk about
uh having the Crimea issue the
occupation of Crimea should be resolved
in a diplomatic format maybe like 10
years later globally the issue needs to
be resolved such as the end of warfare
and then diplomacy steps in
diplomatically we can find a solution
because Ukraine is a peaceful
peace-loving nation and I said this uh
in answering to your first question
it is what matters most is to save as
many lives around people as possible we
do need guarantees of security from
leading Nations and the Russian
Federation understands that we may have
argument about this uh or that country
but among the key states there have to
be guarantors
and those can be members of NATO or
those outside it and we are talking
about key players uh consider key
players of the world but once again I'm
saying that we want those countries that
want it join this openly in addition to
the U.S Great Britain Germany France
turkey
why I named this list this is not all of
them we would like
to have China join it we understand that
Russia needs to find a place in that
agreement as well because it will be an
agreement between Ukraine and Russia so
that because they are a party to this
war they are a subject of this
aggression Invasion and they need to be
bound by that treaty
and I know that several different
countries want to be a member of this
Alliance
uh among the security guarantors for
Ukraine I know Israel and Ireland
Etc
but for now
I only named those countries which have
already said that they are prepared to
be guarantors
or those who we contacted
and already exchanged some early drafts
of the documents about them being so
short of NATO short of Article 5
protection you're saying a group of
Nations provide security guarantees as
President Biden offered the U.S as one
of those countries
we talked with President Biden
just we talked with him quite often
often enough we had a conversation
yesterday
we are saying that Ukraine would like to
see among the leaders of those
guarantors those who are joining this
important piece a settlement process we
would like to see the United States led
by the president among those leaders
and on our part we received a message
that the United States are considering
this proposition they're considering it
in a positive way we want to see
specific guarantees what will be our
future if we now make an agreement with
Russia but two years later they come
back with another War what will happen
not in the next uh three weeks or a week
but or a year we want to know what will
happen within the first hours of a new
war if American intelligence says that
there may be an invasion starting in
January then what will there be
prevention sanctions
will there be pressure
on those individuals who push for
escalation what will be further steps
regarding weapons regarding troops there
are many questions
and we would like to have answers
even if not much but some specific
answers Mr President what do you think
Vladimir Putin wants Vladimir Putin
wants the world and Western countries
what they give to him then appetites
usually grow I think the president of
the Russian Federation is not an
exception if you look in the historical
times and many people have such
appetites grow the more you you give
them the more their appetite grows in
terms of territories so
those appetites keep growing and then
your surroundings keep saying believe me
now is the time to take this step
that surrounding usually creates some
kind of information bubble around the
leader now you live in that information
environment that they created for you
when you begin to live in such a world
then
that's you get such information and then
you try to undertake certain Solutions
which are terrible
not a civilized not uh Democratic but
some kind of authoritarian that's how
they took our Crimea they took away our
donbass and now they want to take more
of our territory we will not let them
because one can't do things like that
someone has to stop it
if not us then there'll be others after
us Europe countries of Europe the
European Union
the former Soviet republics and then of
course Poland Romania
and and so on those are big plans so
that's what he wants
and he will get it unless he is stopped
they talk about the ambition to bring
back the former Soviet uh countries into
back into the Russian Federation saying
that their territory is much bigger than
what they have and it goes way outside
of today's uh borders of the Russia
Federation so what he wants
is his personal business the question is
about us what we can allow him to get
our military experts believe that you
want to build on recent successful
Ukrainian counter-attacks by expanding
to kind of a counter-offensive phase and
that's why you're requesting all these
Advanced weapons like long and mid-range
air defense combat aircraft tanks
armored vehicles counter battery radar
Etc our people also believe that the
Biden Administration is resisting this
in some way is that true are they
resisting that effort
regarding heavy weapons everything's
very simple if the world is ready to
tell the truth to their people if we
don't have heavy weapons how can we
defend ourselves how can we fight
against one of the strongest armies in
the world our military our people our
soldiers are stronger than the Russian
Federation but they have a lot more
weapons so these forces are not equal
and they will say excuse me you now have
enough of what you what you were given
and we cannot go and die for your
territory these are serious challenges
uh powerful weapons are needed to
ukrainians heavy weapons will give us an
opportunity to talk with them at the
negotiation table do you believe that
President Biden wants Ukraine to win or
that President Biden and his
administration fear Putin's reaction if
Russia loses
I have faith
that President Biden like any true
American citizen believes and wants the
truth to win and the truth is on this
side of Ukraine
I believe that they want the values that
make our Nations closer to win that's
Freedom that's democracy freedom of
speech freedom to choose
freedom to choose your dignified life
work who to live with who to love how
many children to have
and I think that those values are close
to every human being we want simple
peace for our nation we don't want
a million of uh quality
um
bulletproof vests or some special brand
helmets just give us missiles
give us airplanes you cannot give us
F-18 or f19 or whatever you have give us
the old Soviet planes
that's all give them into my hands give
me something to defend my country with
my state and if you want it and I
believe that the United States the
people of the United States
want that but if this process gets
longer
continues to be delayed
if we can see that this the process of
transferring those weapons is getting
slower then
people
begin to ask the question is it really
true
maybe there is some game behind it I
don't want to believe that some some
partners of ours are playing uh games I
don't know if President Biden is uh
fearing President Putin
I don't I believe that he doesn't I want
to believe that he doesn't
because he's the leader of a big nation
a great nation I'm holding my fist
that's our tradition I don't know if you
understand this uh this standard you I
hold my fists or cross my fingers
so that this will never happen
that any president of the United States
would fear uh
uh Russia because America for us was
always a symbol of democracy and I have
faith that
Ukraine is also now for Ukraine you're
also a symbol of Freedom Mr President
did you order the attack into Russian
soil the Ukrainian uh helicopter attack
on a Russian military Depot across from
kharkiv across the border in Russia
I'm sorry I do not discuss any of my
orders as commander-in-chief
uh the leader of this state and there
are things which I only share with the
military uh for armed forces of Ukraine
and when they talk with me you need to
understand that on that territory that
you uh
mentioned you have to know they were
placing their shooting systems and
firing those uh those uh missiles
themselves and I know in some regions
this path to mariopal we had made a deal
with the Russian Federation to open that
corridor
they went people went but then the
Russians shot at them and they said no
we didn't shoot but they controlled 140
kilometers of that road
our forces were not there and they shot
many of those convoys and Russians were
saying we ordered not to shoot so
in those temporarily occupied
territories there are all kinds of
things happening which do not balance
uh the military uh do uh looting
marauding
it's not just Russian uh soldiers we
know that there are some Wagner group uh
Fighters and there are chechnya Fighters
uh Chesney guards
and some syrians all kinds of uh
Fighters there so what's happening there
the Russians don't May might not even
know fully what happens there
what matters for us
is that you and the whole world should
know
that we are a country at War
we were attacked
that is what matters that is the biggest
tragedy but honestly
it's not professional to to talk about
it they occupy their territory they
attacked us it's been uh this war been
going on for eight years so whatever
happens in a certain situation I it's
hard for me to comment well Vladimir
Putin's History Mr President on
ceasefires for example is that he uses
them to rebuild his forces Advance
tactically he always breaks the
ceasefire at least in the past by
initiating military action if for
example Mario Paul Falls
to the Russians some observers believe
that Putin may offer a ceasefire in
order to stop your successful counter
offenses and then have time to rebuild
his forces would you accept a ceasefire
regarding uh an actual ceasefire
I don't think that it will be real until
we have reached that an agreement with
the leaders like I said an agreement can
only be made with guarantors of our
security yes there may be an agreement
about this or that regime for ceasefire
for a day or two for instance to collect
the wounded
and the dead bodies of Ukrainian
soldiers from mariopal that's under
blockade the president of Russian
Federation may use that time in order to
withdraw his troops back to the east to
strengthen his position there I am sure
that such a strategy is likely uh to be
considered by President Putin's uh
military uh leaders but if we do get
uh a one-day ceasefire or some hours of
ceasefire in order to be able to help
our people
those people are waiting for our help
we don't care about the tactics of
Russian Federation we will gladly accept
such a ceasefire in order to help our
people that's number one number two
this strategy of uh taking Ukraine in
three days or five days this already uh
a matter of the past let's not forget
that it failed and we will stand
defending us and we will be the first
ones
among
those who want uh to finish the war
diplomatically and we will always
support it from the beginning we were
speaking in favor of Peace but we are
fighting on our territory but everybody
must know
that
if we are pressed in a corner on our
territory we will respond
the way we can
in order to save as many Our Lives as we
can we will answer at full strength and
what's your final message for Vladimir
Putin I wish him to watch television
that is not Russian to see what really
is happening in the world
it doesn't mean
Mr President we appreciate your time on
behalf of Special Report and Fox News
thank you so much it was a great honor
all the best luck for all Americans
thank you thank you hi winner Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now